-Our first guest tonight i
a Golden Globe-winning actor
and best-selling author
you know from his work
in "The X-Files" and
"Californication."
His latest novel,
"Truly Like Lightning,"
is available now.
Please welcome back to the sho
David Duchovny.
How are you, David?
-Seth, I'm good. How are you
-I'm good.
I have heard tell that you are
snowed in in a Pittsburgh hotel.
-Well, either that, or I'm lying
because I purchased the
background "Pittsburgh Hotel
for all my visual calls.
What do you think?
-Oh, yeah, it's like...
[ Laughs ] It's very hard
to tell, but that...
You know, my dad's from
Pittsburgh.
That looks very much
like one of their curtains
-Yeah, I feel good about it.
-[ Laughs ]
So, you know, a lot of peopl
have taken up different skills
during quarantine, and you hav
taken up cooking.
How is that going?
-Uh, not well.
I feel that the smoke alar
in my building
is very sensitive, because..
-[ Laughing ] Okay.
-Yeah, I just have a persona
vendetta with the smoke alar
because every time -- I'm very
afraid of undercooked meat
I've been cooking for my son
and I want to nourish him,
of course, but I don't wan
to kill him
with the undercooked meat.
So I just burn everything.
And the smoke alarm goes
every time I cook.
And my son,
it's like Pavlovian --
he comes out of the room
as soon as the smoke alarm goes.
He comes out of the room jus
whipping this towel like thi
to stop it, while my dog
cowers in the corner
because there's some kind of -
there's a primal fear
of that sound in dogs.
You know, it's so high
and piercing.
And so I've got this dog
pissing itself in the corner
and my son acting like Superma
and I'm burning whatever meat --
Or tofu.
I'll burn anything.
-So, you don't feel as thoug
you've made any progress
over the course of this last
almost year?
-No, I'm confused over the
designation "medium-high."
You know, when they say
medium-high, I don't quite..
That's high to me.
I go right to high.
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
Well, now, that seems to b
on you.
-[ Laughs ]
-Now, I --
See, my thing is chicken.
Like, I wouldn't worry about
undercooking meat
because, you know, a lot o
places, they'll just eat..
You know, a lot of people like
meat rarer than I will eat it,
but I feel like
you're gonna be okay.
When I cook chicken,
my wife is always --
she asks me so many times,
"Did you cook it enough?"
that I feel like, by the end
it's like chicken jerky.
-Yeah, they put the fear of Go
in you with that,
you know, that one time.
You know, the salmonella.
Salmonella!
-And then, you know, you touch
the chicken
and everybody's like, "Did you
wash your hands
after you touched the chicken?
At some point, it's like,
"You know what? Enough."
-It's like the board
that you cut it on,
you've got to put it in the fire
and then you've got to scatter
the ashes
in four different spots.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-What's going on?
-You know, and then I'm like
"Wait a second.
The last time you cooked
chicken, you didn't have t
go through all that stuff.
Why is it, like, these
different rules for me?"
-That's right.
-Yeah.
I'm glad we're getting
to the bottom of this.
Does your son appreciate -
-Fox Mulder could figure it out.
-Does your son appreciate
that he's got a dad
who cooks for him?
-I don't think so.
[ Laughter ]
You know, actually, he does.
That's not right.
I think he's really kind o
touched by my attempts.
And I'm touched by
his cast-iron stomach
for putting it in.
[ Laughter ]
-You guys are a nice match
that way.
-We are.
-So, you actually,
in all seriousness,
you had COVID
this past November.
-I did. I did.
-I'm happy to see
you're recovered.
Was it a tough go?
[audio drop]
...for me, you know?
And I did it -- I went through
it with my son in the apartment,
so we kind of cordoned off
the two areas where I would be
and where he would be.
And, you know, I'd kind of
FaceTime with him
from my room to his,
and it was kind of sweet.
-Oh, well, that's very nice.
I want to talk about your book
This is your fourth book,
which is...
We've talked about the fac
that you're also an author
when you've been here
in the past.
And before I talk about th
book,
I realized as I was
looking at it, I'm like,
alright, one advantage tha
you would have as an actor
is your book jacket photo,
and it's really good.
I mean, obviously,
I feel like you have...
I mean, that's not fair
to other authors out there
Like, the very fact that you
knew to, like,
look off over here.
-You know, that was actually -
We were in Russia playing musi
like 2 1/2 years ago,
and that was taken in Russia
So that's my Russian photo
-Four books.
Do you like the process?
I mean, when I write, I'm very
when my writing is finishe
and I look back at it fondly
but I will admit
that in the moment,
I do not like writing.
Do you?
-Uh, I like having an idea
that I'm trying to write.
Like you, I don't -- you know,
the process of writing is --
it's very difficult.
And, but the end result,
you know, when you've crosse
the finish line or whateve
and you've written something
there's nothing quite like
that sense of accomplishment
at least for me,
because it just feels
completely organic to yourself
You know, it's just somethin
that happened
between you and the page
or the computer or whatever.
So, I know that that's kind of
out there if I can get there
but, you know, the process o
doing it is really just
a daily battle with, you know,
failure, basically.
And frustration, you know?
-And this was an idea
that you had...
The seeds of this idea
were planted years ago
when you were writing an
"X-Files" script, correct?
-Yeah. Yeah, I kind of based the
character on a Mormon forger
a guy who forged scandalou
Mormon documents
knowing that the church woul
then buy it up to suppress them.
He had this amazing gig goin
for a while.
And I kind of read a littl
about Mormonism at that point,
and then I created
this Hollywood stuntman
who retires and goes into
the desert to raise his family
He converts to Mormonism
and he raises his family
totally off the grid,
and for some reason, which you
learn when you read the book
he has to send three of his kids
back into high school
in Rancho Cucamonga in order t
like apply himself to the law.
And then,
it becomes this amazing story.
If you could imagine like thre
kids who have been raised --
they have never met
another human being.
They have never seen
a cell phone,
they have never seen a TV,
and now they're in
suburban Southern California
-And how -- I mean, I woul
imagine you have to do
a fair amount of research
in something, you know,
a religion that obviously
you don't practice
before you write about it.
-Well, yeah.
And I'm really lazy, Seth,
so research is not my bag,
you know.
[ Laughter ]
So I was like --
I just like to get down
and start writing.
But I figured I was going to
have to go to Utah, you know
because I figured that's
where most of the Mormons ar
and I figured that's where
the story would happen,
so I kind of found out
some research and I said,
"Can you tell me where
there are pockets of Mormons,"
kind of hoping that there woul
be a pocket of Mormons
somewhere that I knew the land
you know,
where I wouldn't have to g
live for a year.
And lo and behold, it turns ou
that Mormons founded
San Bernardino.
And I had no idea.
So, all of a sudden,
I could write an L.A. stor
and I could put a bit of a spoof
of Hollywood
in the middle of this book
which is what I do.
So I was like, "oh, I don't need
to travel anywhere."
I could write this book
just sitting on my ass
in my trailer in Malibu.
-[ Laughs ]
Well I'm glad that the lazie
option presented itself to you
-Sometimes, you know, laziness
can be the mother of invention
I'm not sure that's how th
saying goes, but it can be true.
-Now that I think about it
you mentioned that
it's a Hollywood story as well
and the stuntman who's
sort of the main character
-Yeah.
-Is he like stuntmen
that you have worked with
in the past?
Have you had close relationships
with stuntmen over the years
-[ Laughs ]
-Professionally.
-I feel like you're really
digging in there.
-[ Laughs ]
You seem like a guy who woul
fall for a stuntman.
-[ Chuckles ]
They're very macho.
Yeah. I mean, it is just a world
that I knew, obviously.
Just the world of making movie
and television or Hollywood.
And I kind of was able,
because of --
and I understood kind of the -
I guess really what it is, Seth,
is the athleticism of it.
I loved playing sports
when I was younger,
and there is a certain kind of
professional athleticism
to being a stuntman
that it's tougher to get older
You know, it is tougher
when you can't play ball
like you used to,
so I understood
his kind of searching
at a certain point in his life
for that immediacy
of physical contact and risk
-And now, this has
actually been optioned
to be a television show.
You were going to play
this main character,
but you were not
going to adapt your own work
Is that correct?
-No.
No, no, no, no, no.
-Why were you hesitant?
Because obviously,
you have written televisio
and you've wrote the book
that this television
will be based on.
-It's almost like, "Hey,
loved the monologue, Seth.
Could you sing it now?
Could you sing it for us?"
-Oh, my God. I'm so glad
someone finally asked.
[ Laughter ]
-Can you do it as a play?
-Right, right.
-Can you build a building
that looks a little
like your monologue?
You know,
it's just the idea of --
And also because
I love collaboration.
I have no interest
in just filming the book.
The book is written.
The book is what it is.
I would like
to make something new,
and that happens
with collaboration.
-That's really exciting.
I have also heard
that you are --
I feel like we're all having
a different reaction
to this new political
moment we're living in.
You know, mine is a relief
But you're missing --
are you missing it a little bit?
-Well, I -- the truth is, Seth
that I -- you know,
of all the Donald Trump
impersonations,
yours is my favorite.
I don't think
it's the most accurate.
But, no, no, no.
I mean, you're not like
an impersonator,
but what you do, it is hard fo
me to put my finger on it
because your Trump is --
he's got a certain kind of joy
in him that Trump doesn't have
There is a certain kind of
childish-like wonder
in your Trump
that I wish Trump had
but he doesn't.
And when I see you do it,
I just -- I laugh.
I just love your Trump.
So I guess I miss your Trump
I don't miss Trump,
but I guess with Trump gone,
hopefully,
I will miss your Trump.
-That's very kind.
My whole goal
was that he would see it
and aspire
to be my version of him.
-I appreciate that.
And like a good critic,
I think you were trying
to help the nation,
and I'm sorry
that it didn't work out.
-Thank you for -- It's nice to
finally hear that from someone
Thanks so much.
It's always such a pleasure.
-Before you kick me off,
was that a conscious decisio
on your guys' part?
Because it's so not part o
who he is,
that kind of --
he was childish, but --
-There have been -- I have mad
zero conscious decisions
about any impressions
I have done
since I started doing this show,
which is a great departure fro
how much I thought about the
when I did them way worse
at "SNL."
-Really?
-You know, I feel like I put
so much thought into them
that they were without joy
-Right.
-And so, I think the lack of -
Yeah.
I also think that thinking not
at all about a Trump impressio
is helpful because Donald Trum
thinks not at all
about what he says either.
-Well now, I totally screwed u
here because now,
you're going to be thinking,
"Oh, is that what I'm doing?
Now I got to do that."
And I apologize.
But next time I come on,
I want to talk about
all your impersonations.
We're going to
go through them all.
-So we will probably
go through them next week.
-Yeah.
-Thanks, David.